it's good Australia they got a [ __ ]
minute no it's the nickname kingdom of
the world nope they throw them out left
and right you're from [ __ ] the Bay
Area dick hole you're yeah but you live
them yeah but I protect him English
pretension you live in American pretend
'land not a thing you've made it a thing
you've carved out a niche I'm saying
that I'm saying it's not a thing for
sure that's what I am totally what
you've said is not a thing I know yeah
but and it is though no it happened no
no you don't you don't understand know
that you're your say you're sort of
saying like you're accusing me of doing
the passenger site side of some lunatic
you're like Tyler Durden and I'm Edward
Norton and you're a drive in the name
car no no no no no no I'm taking a
sampling of this analogy don't help Airy
Eddy Norton or tie the tiger Denis no
duh or arey
no absolute it's just it's just so great
how much it makes you lose your mind
I mean if you but it was just such it's
not it was never a necessity I feel like
I'll never need it now I think it did
you know it's like they never know
whatever gave the note of like hey how
about some name play have you ever heard
like you traitor no reason have you
heard of the phrase the glue that binds
talking about explain you think the X
Factor in this show is that you called
me Gary and have created this dumb
sidecar sideshow to the yellow that your
stand-up shows Dave I'm not gonna lie to
you at every show I do
one person tries to start it and at some
shows it's happened at most it doesn't
but in every show there's one person
this is your legacy
oh you douche well you're on your couch
watching yeah well this is watching the
Giants play having no clue I started
something that room in the [ __ ] so
while some guys like yeah right I
started something that really doesn't
mean very much and but above you but
books you so much to you and then it
just took on a life of its own it's like
it's just running across the world like
a free animal it bouncing and having fun
no everybody's enjoying it no no not
everybody's enjoying it there's a list
of people not enjoyment they're all
English it's a shorter list yeah they're
English people yeah and they're really
uptight about names just they subscribe
to this theory that the given name is
the name let's do 20 minutes adds you're
listening to the dollop on the all
things comedy Network
it's an American history podcast I
confront this right away each week read
a story from American history to my
friend Gareth G Reynolds has no clue
what the topic is going to be about or
just life in general no no no hey you're
listening to the dollop this is an
American history podcast each week Dave
Anthony disregards a name given to a
baby [ __ ]
look he was just trying to teach the
baby to lighten up no just take it on
level he you know you're like he doesn't
hear it and this is not gonna come to
tickly quad confession now hit him with
the puppy you both present sick
arguments
doll tour dates coming up you can see me
and my friend we're gonna be in American
leg of the tour will be in Irvine
California on August 15th we'll be in
San Diego on August 16th be in San Jose
on September 11th will be in Sacramento
on September 13 look same sighs oh [ __ ]
I'll start that over we will be on tour
dog tour dates American leg her vine
August 15 San Diego
August 16th San Jose September 11th
Sacramento is September 13th Boise
September 14th Madison October 18th
Milwaukee October 20th and then we head
to Europa and Stockholm on November 10th
Oslo Oslo Oslo on November 12th
Amsterdam the 13th Glasgow the 48 to be
somewhere there's the 15th London the
16th Burmingham the 19th Cardiff the
20th Dublin from the 21st Copenhagen the
24th now when you're that's all November
and I'll be doing substantive comedy
before then I'll be at a laughs Boston
July 19th and 20th Acme comedy club
Minneapolis Minnesota July 30th through
August 3rd impro I'm actually
rescheduling my improv dates in Denver
so when I have them be ready there's
some shenanigans Dave there's your bump
I did not get bumped no there's been a
there's some scheduling issue I guess
I'm not I'm figuring it out but I'm
gonna be back there before I go record
my album which is August 22nd through
the 24th and then I'll also be at
Seattle Washington at the Fremont Abbey
August 17th
how BIG's AOD Gareth Reynolds calm for
all that ticket stuff I don't know I'm
not big this is the comedy underground
store in Seattle yeah
I don't think so I know they parlor live
yeah it was a great room it's gone
whatever everything dies what a great
attitude you have so far we the dollop
are brought to you by quip that's right
an electric toothbrush situation that's
what I'm gonna call it we both use the
quip my whole family uses equip yeah I'm
a huge fan
it does the it tells you when to turn
when you're okay quadrant that done
charge is very next quadrant you have
the charge less for take it to a mirror
stick to mirror which is my favorite
there's watermelon flavored toothpastes
whoa they're going crazy over there do
use that I've tried it wild yeah I bet
yeah they're having some fun over there
so yeah they also have two tooth
toothpastes they have kids brushes same
as the original just smaller that's a
pill for your tiny tiny mouth yeah give
you a tiny mouth it's small yeah yeah
look I'm a head of medically shrunk it
has sensitive sonic vibrations for an
effective clean that's gentle on your
sensitive gums because people like you
brush too hard right
you built in you said you did screw you
built in two minute Tyrel pulses as I
said every 30 seconds reminds you to
switch around multi-use cover this is
the vegan stick this is the greatest
thing you go to hotel you can stick it
on the mirror scent doesn't forget on
the dirty counter or the dirty or the
dirty people have been I sometimes
they'll stick it on my forehead and run
around the room naked and say I'm a
unicorn I'm a unicorn yeah you better if
you did that in your room instead of the
lobby well mmm
brush heads are automatically delivered
I can get them set up every three months
for five five bucks they come new new
head a new battery this is the way to go
so that's why we look whipped it's just
got so many different things going for
it and why I'm taking it to I'm going to
Scotland clip starts at just $25 and if
you go to get clipped calm a slash
dollop right now you can get your first
refill pack for free
that's your first refill pack free at GE
t q UI p comma / dollop
we're also brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is of course is a website
company they have tons of templates you
just go there you build your little
website you see how it looks and then
you can sign up yep we both use
Squarespace use it for your your comedy
business site yep I use it for my comedy
business site we use it for the dollop
sources and and we also use it just for
adult podcast calm so we're all in so we
use it yes we like it and the reason
reason we use is good we enjoy it yeah
so you know they got great templates
like I said world-class designers
ability to customize look feel settings
products and more within just a few
clicks it's you can buy domains choose
from over 200 extensions they got
analytics they got 24/7 ordering it's
all there it's all there
go I don't know why you're complaining I
don't know either
so yeah get on it I think I think that
the this for me the reason I pick
Squarespace is just cuz I think that it
looked the cleanest it looks like the
nicest all their templates look the you
know I like that we understand it yeah
right it helped cuz I've tried I've
tried other other things and I'm I'm not
that bright when it comes to tech stuff
always makes me very it doesn't go well
me in tech okay it's upsetting but with
Squarespace I've always had it easy
[Laughter]
so go over and check out squarespace.com
for a free trial go ahead and set up
your site to check it out and when
you're ready to launch use offer code
dollop to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain that
squarespace.com enter code dollop boom
boom boom
who's gonna complain this week find
someone hey if you guys could just
complain to me if I could wake up in the
morning and open the first email is
someone complaining every day that would
be great I think that's the key I think
that's what you want
right so if you're gonna complain set it
on 4 a.m. you know Pacific standards so
that that's what days we can I mean if
you guys could just keep sending emails
complaining and then it's like it's it's
then you'll text me that so it's like
getting spray it's like a nice early
vibe it's great it's good way to wake up
think you could also send a
complimentary email where you do - no no
no wait you do to compliments and then
the third one is telling us what we do
wrong that also really cool Network you
know do that
yeah those are really good just all that
stuff I just like to wake up to it I
like the first thing in the morning get
slapped in the face least you have to
keep your name if you want to watch this
worth the all things come to YouTube
page yeah
I'm looting the documentary the amazing
Jonathan always amazing it's really good
it's great you should watch it March 7th
1938 yeah little the war yeah ok right
kinda how it started right not for us no
we're for other we're on the beach still
like yeah that's right Janet Guthrie was
born in Iowa not a normal girl for the
time okay she was beyond a tomboy okay
she loved risk okay she loved to read
books about adventures and aviators okay
this seems to have run in the Guthrie
family after her grandparents got
married they went to Scotland for a
honeymoon bottom ohter cycle with a
wicket sidecar and then drove all over
Europe with a wicker sidecar drag and
with Grandma on oh and
she's like her basket not safe I just
got it but it's very it's very Guthrie
right sure the family moved to Florida
and her father built the house they
lived in near Miami sure this has a very
very mid-40s
yep he was a pilot for an airline he was
also not one to play by the rules that's
not great for airline he didn't like the
fact that commercial air we're not
landed no not like that not like that I
mean that's a rule you have to play
about necessarily literally have to play
by that room they can fuel it in the sky
you well I started in one of the movies
maybe Batman what you saw you saw it in
military planes I don't believe they
refueled you jet airliner these things
possible
I'm not according to what I was told on
Twitter all week before I built so he he
didn't like the fact that commercial air
airplanes had to jump excess fuel after
takeoff had to dump excess yeah so they
would just fill it up and then be like
well you got too much fuel so they would
take off and then dump it what is what
why I couldn't figure it out but it was
just a just a giant waste of fuel and
before they would land well it said take
off so yeah then there's no I mean maybe
the person got it wrong and maybe it was
land but either way yeah still like bad
it's lazy he had this weird feeling that
it was bad for the environment right
okay that wasn't all right okay so he
went to the press and told the press
about it sure and of course big story
then he was suspended by his airline
sure but all his fellow pilots rallied
around him and he was reinstated and
then dumping fuel jet fuel was slowly
phased out okay so he you know he's one
of those guys made a changemaker
sure not not afraid to stand up and do
his own thing sure so when Jay was 12
her mom got tuberculosis and had to live
in a sanitarium about 75 miles away
perfect yeah perfect
so Janet's the oldest kid youngest kids
a toddler so great so this is great
because her mother's far away so now she
has to become a mother 12 that's right
that's perfect
well that's what you it's ideal its ID
it's how you want to start your and your
childhood yeah yeah
so a forced Bar Mitzvah it's with no
present no present responsibility and
nobody comes
tons of same interlocks just five other
kids just tons of kids yeah you've got
enough to take care of you change
diapers yeah yeah so so her dad is a
pilot so he like sometimes goes
overnight so she's in charge of the
other kids it's imperfect and Shane the
heating off you don't need that let's
try this she's cooking she's sewing
she's cleaning the house well pastor
Toby old sir what do you want a perfect
yes like a sitcom montage intro yeah
yeah that's right so I took mom about a
year to recover and then she came back
so she says a year of the best
twelve-year-old year ever great when
she's 13
she flew a plane for the first time
perfect you know just normal like this
is what happens when you become a mother
at 12 you can just start doing other
stuff far too early that's right
astronaut at 18 yeah yeah President of
the United States 23 Doogie Howser
yeah the Doogie Howser of history she
read Charles Lindbergh's the spirit of
st. Louis and became obsessed with
parachuting so she wants to jump out of
a plane with a parachute on her dad said
no because you know she's like 14 15
right so when she was 16 she started
jumping off the roof of the house all
summer until he said yes okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yes it's safer than this so he flew he
flew the plane she jumped out she made
it she survived okay um how like I'm
sure you don't know the answer to this
but how where you weren't I mean she was
jumping with someone else who had jumped
before right it I couldn't find that you
know she just talked about herself
jumping I couldn't find anything that
she did with anybody else yeah I'm
curious yeah I mean that's crazy
yep I would certainly have buckled I'd
buckle at this age doing that oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah I would never I don't think
gravity is a toy that's my
so Jana got her pilot's license when she
was 17 years old okay sure but she could
not become a working pilot in 1955
because commercial airlines were not
hiring women pilots I love that it's
that they weren't hiring women not that
she was 17 well but when she turned 18
she couldn't right get a job
the big dishes no women no it's like the
locker room can't have a lady up there I
usually get a bunch you gotta want to
talk about her you know there's stuff
they talk about on the view and whatnot
plus you know I'm a pilot so when I'm
flying the long flight I can take care
of my ball we'd like to be naked up
there let the boys breathe make it up
there flying we're drinking a couple
hams with the pop top if you get a
hard-on probably maybe co-pilots for
maybe your blood study you get more our
tides so we're just a couple of guys
sitting up in the old [ __ ] front or the
cockpit yeah naked having a couple hands
with a couple hard odds listening to
some van Halen are they were invented
Jimmy we're uh over like Denver you want
to give me a little hand oh hey what do
you say uh Rocky Mountain handy about a
mile I job anyway no ladies hey who
would want a lady in here yeah distract
us from drinking beer and jerking each
other off up front so she goes to the
University of Michigan and gets a degree
in physics okay so she's a smarty yeah
and she got an engineering job at an
aerospace company on Long Island and
slowly rose up the rags Jesus and then
she bought a gray a 1953 Jaguar coupe
thank God I wasn't sure if there was
gonna be a car or just an animal and
then she got into car racing okay
interesting and she spent nights working
on the Jag she put all her money into
the kitchen on the Jag that's right yeah
she put all her money to the car
she started racing in gym Kaunas which
are just like a cone core set up in a
parking lot okay
so and then she started winning them I
guess they do like amateur parking lot
races sure she's a demolition derby sort
of style yeah except it's in like the
the park took a Safeway parking lot
gotcha
okay different but she got her she
starts getting a rep is a great driver
in these gym Colonel and whatever their
Jim cotton I'm not talking about racism
all over the Northeast so she won so
much that other drivers started saying
she had a supercharger in our car okay
let me guess these other drivers men men
ah no way lady beats me unless she's got
a fancy special car she's a wizard and a
man's outfit next she started racing in
hillclimbs sure so these are much much
more dangerous than a parking lot a lot
of drivers crash because there's turns
and twists so guys are going over the
side and show that kind of shapes
there's more of a course and well it's
just like like if you miss isn't it too
safe I still it's not too safe right
yeah it's no it's not even a course it's
just up up up up a hill like a hill road
you know it's like all right okay right
there you go up Angeles Crest it's like
that drivers crashed all the time but
Janet was very cool and calm quote I
found that I liked fast courses and fast
turns she rose up the ranks of amateur
drivers she was her own mechanic and she
rebuilt the Jags engine in the back of
her station wagon all by herself just
going by the shop manual
she put a Jaguar engine in a station
wagon just with a manual you're saying
why do you think she wanted to do on the
ground for because I don't know I don't
know how that works is building an
engine me gonna have to suspend it when
you build it sure I'd imagine you can't
just lay it on the grass at some point
you're gonna need it up so yeah I think
that was the but she rebuilt it or or
because she was driving around while
she's off from racing and she's wherever
for the weekend she can work on it right
okay because she's always working on
everything when she's not racing or
okay so she's so she builds a station
yeah she started job she's working 95
and then at night at night she's working
on many moons as a drag panic no night
she's mechanic weekend she's a
generation how the drag racer she's
regular regular write amateur racer
jaguar racer she's a Jag racer jag jag
jag mm-hmm I didn't so so the the shop
manual that's the greatest thing to me
she just built it by a shop manual yeah
she IKEA - motor not normal it was
written in British because it's a Jag so
it had nonsense like extract the mills
pin and removed the driving dog and drop
that look
hoity-toity hoity-toity so her life in
the early 60s is all racing she was a
natural she's very competitive some men
couldn't handle losing to a woman or he
could imagine in that day yeah in 1966
she came in second and heard the winner
time the guy who came in third quote
it's no disgrace to be beaten by her
yeah no it is goddamn it I had a [ __ ]
yeah it is it is shocking how much that
changes everything
yeah like I could handle losing to a man
she's not a man not this problem
a woman racing was considered just a
non-starter by a lot of male drivers
Grand Prix driver
Francois Guevara here we go was asked if
women could compete quote oh I don't
think that would be very good I think
they're missing something between the
legs yes don't have a thing between the
legs that we do they have what there's
no be trying to have sex with the gear
she yes I have a penis oh wow okay yeah
yeah and she's got like a riders helmet
on distracted recipes oh she wants me at
the fuck-ass that's the Jag Wow so
that's pretty cool right yeah yeah
that's a cool [ __ ] car looks like
she's driving a pinewood derby car so
apparently a lot of men said that that
you need to [ __ ] and balls and was the
recurring state Dave in this day and age
I bet you a doctor said it but Janet
still I looked up a lot of articles
about her she still said them at this
point she's still saying most drivers
are super nice and shocking and and fine
quote the nice thing about sports racing
is that with very few exceptions you're
pretty much accepted on your
capabilities as a driver okay a racing
executive took notice of her skills on
the amateur circuit but told their quote
you will never be a winning driver
because no one will ever give you a
winning car because you're a woman so
she's saying at this point she's saying
nice things in the press right but by
the way totally what you have to do I
think so right yeah I think so yeah slag
them off then they're gonna be like so a
she's Radek that's right she can't say
yeah you create the condition do then
like serve your narrative that's already
carved up so so don't look at the
pictures so so she so she's doing that
but then later on when she recalls and
writes in her life it's a little
different right it's a little like well
there were a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
right she's also very attractive as I
said
this man so a lot of men did not to do
with her because she's like that's a hot
picture right there she didn't seem to
fit into the lives of men she dated
right she worked 9:00 to 5:00 like I
said work on the card night race on
weekends there's not a lot of time for a
dude in there yeah her parents dinner's
gonna be like honey you sure you want to
use that wrench yeah yet nobody uses
French well cuz maybe make a mid-table
should take a look I actually want it to
work so I'm gonna use that yeah all
right well let me know if you need to
tag out and get I got under there for a
minute I don't it all second set of
regular eyes if I do little lady eye
because think only is it truly one eye
works and a lady no they both are
working cuz I lie right right now I'm
looking at a [ __ ] idiot yeah but you
would be able to do that with just the
one because it's like pirate eye anyway
um well let me know if you need help or
anything if you want to help see my no
okay alright well this was a terrible
conversation do you try think what else
I can do because I go away well I let me
make the decision to do that okay I'm
gonna leave oh yeah I know you want me
to hang out help laughing I'm gonna
really hoping you might hang out you
need me to hang out no oh yeah alright
I'm out of here then okay alright what'd
you say nothing
oh I thought used to come in back help
you with the I did not All Right see you
later absolutely did not
sorry I got to leave to this door okay
she she did seem to date a lot of
drivers which would make sense that's
you know Jerry only people that she's
really seeing other than people that
work for parents
Donna stand while she's racing her
brothers and sisters are all working
great jobs now and they've got advanced
degrees it was simple to Janet quote
being a race car driver is what I am
Gianna was eventually laid off by the
aerospace company because she couldn't
fully commit to the job and she got a
job at a smaller aerospace company in
1966 Janet was invited to drive in the
Daytona Continental 24 here then the
smoke
bini she worked for failed and at 29 she
had to make a choice go get her master's
in physics and keep going in aerospace a
girl for broke and get into racing
completely literally decision I had to
make it 29 right it does a stand up I
did the same thing no no I mean with the
exact same jobs oh I don't mind if I
needed to be a racecar driver if I
wanted to get my physics degree I just
want to end the podcast right now that
is a crate that has got to be a very
crazy decision though yeah
clearly go with the one where you don't
need to go to school yeah yeah
I ended up driving let's not ever do
that again okay so the only woman who
had really been successful in racing she
says seem to have private fortunes they
could fall back on right which is also a
common thing and stand up for you
startup yeah Janet chose racing okay in
1967 the New York Daily Record wrote
quote Janet Guthrie is to racing
Janet Guthrie is a this is not written
Janet Guthrie is to racing to a racing
driver
plant and [ __ ] what's the tongue what
time right now so I can okay the jeddak
Guthrie is a racing driver plane pilot
sky jumper and guess what a physicist
working on a rocket systems for a living
tall and slender she has hazel eyes
light brown hair and a faint dusting of
freckles
literally so pervy literally every
article I read and I mean I mean into
the 70s everyone starts with what she is
and then goes into what she looks like
well eight that's that's a wind minor
wind that they're starting with the
substance but you can also describe a
tunnel exit out feeling so creepy
no you're adjusting like you don't even
need to say she has freckles mmm
a dusting of freckles her hair like
angels whispers clothing smells of ocean
breeze
sweet sweet Janet one can only imagine
her toes taste of coconut oil honey I'm
reading the paper I'm gonna go look in
the shower for a little bit you're gonna
read the paper in the shower yeah okay
bye
so Janet and says in the paper to go to
the shower go to your shower gel you
sure I gotta go to my shower there's a
dusting of freckles happening so she
also was she started every year racing
in this the severing 12-hour race I
think it's in Florida and she teamed up
with other women because at the towbar
race so I mean check I mean right though
that that absolutely gorgeous woman is
from like Denmark or something but she's
over here racing okay so they're like so
then would team up yeah and then they do
the trouble our race together yeah Paul
Hawkens an Australian racer was not
happy quote those bloody birds don't
belong on a race course they belong
either in the kitchen or in the bedroom
no one wants to see some granny driving
a school bus out there keep the bloody
birds off the course there's so many
flags to throw
well I gotta say the key I got I gotta
get some granny driving a school bus out
there was a pretty good like it's a but
read that part again that's the part
that I'm like no one wants to see some
granny driving a school bus out there so
he's just saying the racers get mad when
people drive slow right and so he's
saying they're driving too slow right
okay
he blamed them for causing him to crash
the year before but photographers had
absolved them right shocking yeah in
1971 Janet became the first professional
woman driver in a SCCA series whatever
it's a [ __ ] sure at the time weren't
women weren't even allowed in pits at
NASCAR okay so women are forbidden in
pits and gas an alley at NASCAR okay a
woman named Pat Wagner asked for Pitt
credentials at Daytona in 71 and was
quote spat at her coat lapels ripped off
locked in a men's bathroom and doused
with urine what Jesus Christ look she
shouldn't have asked no no she I mean
she asked for something she you just say
no yeah you don't need to lock her into
a John and piss on her oh oh [ __ ]
because we have a whole kid over here
for one and a woman asked for not huge
them yeah there's a kid there's a thing
to rip off stuff oh no there's a there's
a jar spitting there's a jar urine
you're supposed to drink the jar spit
and then spit it on ur shrink the jar of
spit yeah in case you don't have enough
ready and then and then the orange is
always there it's just in case a woman
wants credentials it's old piss yeah
class of Kentucky more downside yeah oh
it's Kentucky yeah it's golden yeah
agent oak barrels well this is where we
stored a piss for throwing so another
woman sued to get into the Indy 500 pit
and the judge ordered women be allowed
in okay
fans in the stands booed the first women
who went into the pit I'm shocked so
they open it up and Pratt basically it's
press Rosco's
dried the ring as fans have always been
on the right side of history yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah always yeah yeah yeah
driver cale yarborough said quote I hope
somebody runs over one of them with one
of those tractors what the [ __ ]
driver AJ Foyt quote decent women know
their place a seething guard at the gate
said to a reporter quote pigs that's
what they are pigs
what in the [ __ ] is happening HS and
also you know I mean obviously you know
the answer to this but it's like just
beat up just mop the floor with them
then yeah then you can be like that's
useless you know
like then instead of being like before
anything really happens even other women
were against the intrusion the wife of a
car owner said angrily quote there are
just certain places where women don't
fit so now once that like being asked
their opinion on women that's right so
it was over everywhere once the Andy pit
was open it was all pits right right the
Austin American paper quote women's lib
has struck again
NASCAR's no women in the pits and garage
garages rule is no more a lady named
dusty brand L was in the pits at Ontario
for the Miller 500 like that's news
mm-hmm that's news yeah woman was there
and in 1973 Jayne won her class in the
North American Road racing championships
she was getting help from Toyota so
that's I think I showed that earlier but
she says she Toyota's like giving her a
little bit of help
her name is jammers yeah but I think
it's like local Toyota sort of
dealerships that are doing it okay
she's mostly doing all her own she's
basically paying for it all on her own
still so it's it's wearing her down it's
like we said you think of her schedules
so now we're [ __ ] years into it yeah
she bought a Toyota Celica and built it
up from scratch then crashed it at 36
she was living in a tiny apartment with
no savings
she was single she had no problem
meeting men several had proposed but
Shannon told them all they had to do was
agree that she could keep racing and
none of them did late in 1973 a man
named a Rolla Volstead was looking for a
female driver for the Indianapolis 500
okay
so Roland is here and Roland is he's a
good guy in 1973 it was the war with
Billie Jean King beat Bobby Riggs in a
tennis match or that was a big [ __ ]
festival the first female jockey won a
stakes race and Volstead thought using a
female driver would make a big splash
huh
he's a low-budget independent team owner
so he has to take chances to win okay
he had a lumber business and he just
loved racing so he's pouring it all into
racing he called des CCA and Janet's
name was at the top of the list as far
as female drivers go many men in racing
would publicly say a woman could not
race TV commentators said a woman
couldn't last a 500-mile race others
said women were a danger because they
would faint at fast speeds that's that
that that well no I mean we're having
fun but we all we've seen I mean I take
flights a lot I mean we both fly a lot
like you know what it's like yeah the
second you get up there it's just like a
woman genocide I mean it's just body it
went bodies all over the only time I'm
on a plane like it's the women well
that's why that's why all the flight
attendants are male yeah that's right
yeah because they go yeah fast they're
out well they can't do the food and
beverage that's right they're just well
they're laying on the floor legs on the
floor
yeah like just I wish the doctors can
figure out what causes that it's the
speed they can't they're not how to what
in their body because they because
there's actually there's really the same
as I suggest where they have different
organs Jack's like a sail and speeds and
it sort of is able to slow us down and
we can kind of be anchor and my vagina
more takes in its aerodynamic yeah so
it's sort of like they they are treated
more like an out-of-control kite right
and
we're more just like an anchor like a
bullet like a bullet exactly and there
and there and they're taking the air in
yeah I mean don't get too super fixed
right right I'm just saying well let's I
think we can keep it above belt a little
bit but you know let's just say there's
it's it's different strokes for
different folks right yeah so their
cookies just getting air blasted and
they pass out can I can we pause the
podcast then can I talk to you outside
for five minutes just five so a few said
women wouldn't be able to raise if they
were menstruating cuz how could that I
mean how do you be called woman
straining cuz how how could you imagine
a woman be able to function as a human
being while menstruating yeah yeah it's
not anything I feel like she's a better
racer at the Indy 500 not one woman had
even tried to qualify okay it's the big
race right it was it was just four years
since women had been booed for going
into the pit in 71 so Janet got some
coverage in the papers
Ruth cling wrote an article for the New
York Daily News with the headline racing
cars keeps her trim and fit what Ruth
don't help this is that picture again
which is what was nice article quote
more and more women are invading sports
that were considered the domain eating
yeah there's some interesting yeah what
were considered this is written by woman
I know yeah they were considered the
domain of men and in doing so they are
giving up nothing Janet Guthrie
is a perfect as perfect proof of this
she has been a race racing car driver
for 12 years yet manages to look pretty
slender well-spoken and feminine but she
also like lived in a one-bedroom
apartment like or like lived a lot I
mean what she's just saying she's just
but all she's saying is she's still
available for a man to marry
oh she's literally saying she's still
useful as a wife
oh god it's an older model but she's
still drivable it's the New York Daily
News
yeah now that was that in the sports
section because it's sugar
anyway Rolla Bolla stat bought thought a
woman driver would be better than a male
driver quote God made women better able
to handle stress than men women are
calmer and cooler plus women's lib was
super hot at the time and he thought
sponsors would be into it so he reaches
out to Janet great for some reason Janet
is weary at first but he keeps pushing
and for a year and a half they discussed
it back and forth Volstead lead driver
was a guy named dick Simon dick is
that's not my ring tone I have a dick if
we can do me a favor after the show just
highlight that and then let's just take
that I have a dental section no Dave
we've got what we need if we got what we
came here for I can so if you can just
identify to play I like that and then
well I just want to make that a ringtone
and a ringtone available for everybody
so during one race a Dix cockpit caught
on fire
Dave I'm trying lining up and it burned
the skin off his leg down to the bone
yeah his crew told him to get out and
not finish the race yes quote I was
running well and there was no way I was
going to get out of that car and he went
back out and he won the race what and
then he came into the pit and passed out
later racing officials told him to go
see a psychiatrist yes
so races are a different type of human
yes yeah well they yeah I mean they're
just I mean you're literally putting
your life on the line to win a race like
it's different Creed dangerous so that's
that's the type of guy he is right
old-school tough guy the kind of guy
who's you can see his femur and he'll
finish that's right so Jenna was the
only woman with the Indy 500 as a goal
another woman Arlene
Hisss was also shooting for the new 500
now I couldn't find any record of it but
boy a Janet said she said basically said
everyone who she made it sound like
everyone who was not in her place was
wealthy so the other women who were
racing were able to do it at a mortgage
yes not have a job and Bob I couldn't
find any indication that that was true
but you know I will give her the benefit
of the doubt okay so uh Arlene hiss
she's trying to get into any 500 when
people heard she was going to enter they
were not happy from a letter and the
national speed sports news quote I hope
that all he men would boycott the race
if miss hiss is allowed to drive if
there was a terrible wreck just what
would she do
faint that letter was written by a woman
two weeks before the tryout for Volstead
Janet broke her foot she knew her trial
would be gone and he'd move on to the
next woman so she didn't tell him now
her foot was green yellow and dark
purple and that's a good color those are
all not not new normal writing colors so
she went to Miami or I guess she was
living in Miami oh no she's in Miami and
she goes to the doctor or he's like pull
of cash she's like no and then an
orthopedist who works at the Miami
Dolphins comes to look at it and he said
the metatarsal that was broken was the
exact one that you used to break so it's
like the one that you put all the
pressure on he told her she could race
if she had no plans to ever stop the car
perfect and they put a cast on her now
Janet knows if Arlene his-- is first in
the Indy 500 she gets all the attention
and all the sponsorships and then she's
not gonna be able to do what she wants
to do so hiss became the first woman to
get a US auto club license which means
she can drive an IndyCar races
and Janet's on crutches so Janet goes to
New York and begs a doctor who is known
for having bad ethics to take the cast
off but he's like no so three days
before she was supposed to do the tryout
with Volstead oh no she soaks in a bath
ripped off the plaster cast with her
hand Jesus Christ and then Janet fled to
Ontario California for the test and
there she met dick Simon now dick is
Volstead lead driver right of his team
and Janet said she was Limpy because she
twisted her ankle and it wasn't a big
deal
she wore a driver suit she had sewn
herself over the years to save money and
that she got into her first IndyCar ever
she had never been in one
she'd never gone over 130 miles an hour
and she got the cop to 161 and realize
she could work the brake the next day
she went a hundred and seventy two point
four miles an hour which is faster than
Simon had ever gone in the car okay she
was now part of the team Simon was very
impressed with her the announcement went
out that she was going to race at Indy
and the press did the usual thing and
then hate-mail poured in one quote you
are either a neuter or a lesbian
another quote a phony non talented
inarticulate man hating money-grabbing
hysterical [ __ ] she's tones of letters
like this just pouring in so she's
running into this tidal wave of sexism
and she's completely shocked by the
amount of it that's coming her way she
didn't expect it meanwhile hiss is in a
race in Phoenix and that race became all
about whether or not women should be
able to race at all uh-huh so Janet flew
out to watch she's rooting for his to do
well because she knows if his blows it
then all the hateful men will say
they're right oh yeah yeah when we can't
do it huh and hiss was terrible yeah she
was slow tentative kept signaling kept
safe
uh and she's getting lapped constantly
she clogs up the fast lane now when your
that's like the I mean if you're her
watch it they like you Tama a snow yeah
the one thing you can't do is Club and
fast lane because that causes accidents
yeah you're just supposed to get out of
the way and let the other guys go by you
but she's clogging up the fast lane it
looks like she's forgotten how to race
like it's just crazy and then finally a
race official waves the black flag at
her for breaking the track rules and
takes her out of the rest [ __ ] so it
didn't go great
she was lapped 22 times and last place
total disaster couldn't have gone worse
the male racers just [ __ ] go off one
said hiss would kill someone if they
didn't take away her racing license
Bobby unser said quote it is a sad day
when some woman gets in a car and pokes
around the track slower than anybody
else and then all the riders and
television cameras crowd around and
ignore the professionals he said he
spent years learning and coming up the
ranks but these women were doing it
differently quote now here come these
women with these dinky little
experiences in dinky little cars with
little horsepower so what he's saying is
well not true for anyone not true at all
for a for his or Janet this is less
prepared to do this and this just opens
the door to now crazy theories and [ __ ]
well is it makes Janet is his less
prepared after the race his told Janet
that one of her crew members told her to
go as slow as she wanted and to stay in
the fast lane and not get out well
that's good so even her own crew were
trying to undermine that just savagely
sabotage her so Janet faced the press
and said male rookie drivers who had bad
races didn't get these kind of attacks
so next was the Trenton - honey that is
very true I mean yeah right that's right
I'll ever raise the net in that level so
uh the Trenton 200 was going to be
Janet's first race and that's like a
month before the Indy 500 this was
supposed to be there but a group of male
drivers were organizing to stop her they
told the USA see that they would boycott
the race if hiss raced and she was
forced to drop out the USAC didn't want
a woman in it that's right hiss would
race in NASCAR but never again get a
chance an IndyCar she would drop out in
a couple years
drop on a racing completely and teach
dancing instead quote wait all the men
were like that's why I told you what she
should be doing at her quote I hated
that it stopped it really wasn't a
decision I made it was made for me
so Janet holds a press conference before
Trenton with hit with his spout all the
attentions on her for two months there
were just tons of men in the racing
world explaining how women can't handle
cars drivers and owners pressured race
officials to ban Janet the New York
Times wrote an article about Janet and
above the story was a Rodney Dangerfield
joke because quote my wife drove oh no
not a good start um you know as to be
proven with Rodney's material couldn't
be more true when it comes to the
woman's land my wife drove into a tree
today but she told me it wasn't her
fault she blew her horn New York Times
above an article about one of the first
women racecar drivers driver David Bowie
she took out two bridges I told my wife
to bridge off she drove a car watch free
driver David Pearson said quote she
ought to be home having babies if she
can no it doesn't have the Dangerfield
timing hey she should be home having
babies if she even okay I mean it would
guess so he's saying two things she's a
woman she should be home a baby but
she's also not a woman just not a woman
she can have babies okay Bobby unser
took every shot he could so utters kind
of becoming the unofficial spokeswoman
for misogynist [ __ ] against Oaks
person spoke spokesman yeah so there's a
I took the I found the best picture of
him I could it's a good one it says dick
yeah so quote what does Guthrie been
driving Jaguars why when I was fifteen
or sixteen i street Jaguars down the
highway and if I ever tried entering
Indianapolis you think I wouldn't have
been laughed at Janet called Bobby a
chauvinist pig the press started calling
it Janet Guthrie versus Bobby unser
Janet's car was difficult and Anita work
so she doesn't have a great car that's
interesting about racing that I didn't
know is you know the guys who are super
fast or win a lot of races they have
tons of money and they have better cars
yeah so when you're starting out you
have a shitty car you have your work
grabbed a better car so like you really
had to prove yourself so this car kind
of sucks it's barely capable what a true
when a crew would try to borrow parts
from other crews they wouldn't help
because it was for a woman right this
caused Janet's crew to get angry and
start to pull together for her nice
reporters follow Jan around NBC miked
her to get every comment she made dick
Simon helped and gave as much advice as
he possibly could and Janet qualified
she raced while at Trenton but the car
gave out on the 79th lap a driver Billy
of Vuckovich who had been giving her
[ __ ] said quote I think she's definitely
more qualified than I thought there we
go
another quote she did an excellent job
it's a shame she didn't have a better
car AJ Foyt walked over to pit row and
congratulated her she'd passed her first
test nice so AJ Foyt's like being a nice
guy janet was now world news and she
found her not failing at Trenton just
hardened the [ __ ] who had contempt
at Indy she said quote so she now she's
gone to Indian you go there and you
practice and you're there for a while
right
mm-hmm she said quote hostility hung in
the air drivers mechanics pit crews and
other owners glared at her but she was
now being recognized on the street women
approached her to thank her thankful
letters came in from all over the world
and now she felt more pressure like she
was racing for every woman dealing with
his chauvinist pig in her life so all
women yeah her crew got protective and
nicknamed her Indy lady they put up a
sign quote Andy lady is our lady which
made her almost cry okay Andy was a
notoriously dangerous race and in the
three weeks of practice leading up guys
were crashing their cars one broke his
neck
just before she got into the car like
that Rodney Dangerfield joke my husband
crashed his car into a tree he said it
wasn't his fault
he hooked suggest before she gets in her
car for qualifying she's walking to her
car two guys are drinking beers and they
yell at her that they hoped that she
would crash nice nice stuff guys yeah
you're extras in a movie about her but a
piston blew in the car
the Chicago Tribune mocked her quote
she'll have the car up to qualifying
speeds by 1982 slams roll and they when
Jim was put in the car but the car still
sucked
Mario Andretti told Janet he felt sorry
for her because of the [ __ ] car but she
wasn't able to get upset with Volstead
because he had her back under what Simon
described as quote appalling pressure so
the owner doesn't have his money but
he's still you know there for as much as
he can be the car was just not gonna cut
it it was looking like Janet was not
going to race in the Indy 500 been
national champion known hard man tough
cowboy AJ Foyt offered her his backup
car hmm his crew told Janet they didn't
want her in the car so she goes Everly
the car on the cruise like we didn't
want you driving this [ __ ] car okay
and she told them she'd never destroyed
a car and she wasn't gonna start now so
she tested and she gets up 280 miles an
hour
but after she drove it they go they
bring it in and then flake goes in to
meet with his team and his people and
hours go by and then he takes back the
office so with no explanation he said
she did a terrific job in the tests but
her indi run was over still after all
this women would keep telling her how
much she'd changed things
some said her name was coming up in
office meetings so her growing celebrity
led to a NASCAR race asking her to join
right because she's now a name so they
need people she knew the the NASCAR
people knew she would sell tickets
a female banker in Charlotte North
Carolina at Linda Ferrari which whoa
yeah
offered to back Janet's NASCAR run Linda
was not a feminist or race fan she told
Janet she had been at a party quote
someone took the position that what you
were doing was just a publicity stunt
and you would never make it as a racecar
driver so many people were saying you
were a hoax and that it was impossible
for a woman to compete in the Winston
Cup and I thought to myself wouldn't it
be fun to be part of disproving that how
great is it when you have enough money
to get probably drunk at a cocktail
party get into an argument and then like
pay to prove everyone wrong
I mean yeah like people that never
probably alright settle down I'm gonna
I'm gonna get her into a race all right
let's all let's just let's chill it out
everyone like so she's racing yeah she's
and she's also this Linda Ferrari woman
she's a banker and there's no female
bankers like she's she's like in the
exact same thing but in banking but
they're super friends said she tosses
down 30 grand the NASCAR race was the
world 600 it was the longest NASCAR race
six hundred miles four hours no woman
had ever gone past 200 miles in a NASCAR
race
well they fainted yeah they faint very
easily up they go right yeah they have
to go 30 miles an hour yes some male
drivers used water-cooled helmets and
relief drivers but Janet said no to Beau
the day was announced Jan would race
they sold more tickets than any day in
the history of the track networks
started out bidding each other to get
the rights and usually it was the other
way around where they would try to get
they wouldn't pay the network to put it
on but how great is it that this is all
this is all birthed out of the dumb mail
protest one person just elevated her
status yeah totally
so NASCAR is a different animal in Indy
NASCAR is like the tough-guy racing
thing you know bar born out of moonshine
runners in the South it's like you know
almost all women involved in NASCAR at
this time our beauty queens are fans
asking drivers to sign their boobs okay
Janet said quote this is a part of the
country where women are supposed to be
useless even if they're not they are
supposed to be decorative and that's it
she was annoyed that women I died who
they were and the NASCAR guys were far
bigger dicks than the Andy guys she was
very excited to meet Richard Petty who
was known as the king he is the you know
he's the hot [ __ ] of racing mm-hmm his
dad was a racer his family's all you
know the racer had one hand made a duct
tape yes right so she meets him at a
pre-race party and she's all excited and
he just shot her a nasty look and was
total disdain
there's no women's bathroom because
women aren't racers right so she had to
change every day in the women's bathroom
in the stands and one day she was
suiting up when the wife of a driver
came in and said she'd been working on
her husband's car all night and when
Janet asked her why she wasn't in the
garage with the rest of the crew she
answered quote oh I would never do that
that's for men yeah just yeah like it's
not just it's not just like men keeping
up like there's like a Stockholm
Syndrome so part of this where the women
go would obviously not all women or
nothing would change but there's a group
of women who
are keeping everything the same just as
much as men are yeah like you're working
on the [ __ ] car you should be like no
I'm gonna be in the [ __ ] garage so
she's like well that's not my place I
just do it at night in the shadows I
just do everything i what do I know
Genet qualified in 27th place when the
race started she moved up the pack she's
soaked with sweat the restraint cut her
her skins chafing she almost collided
with Richard Petty as he crashed his car
and then she finished the race in 15th
Wow everyone was excited her crew
members cried like everyone pretty much
oh great they're crying wait but guys
keep it together yeah we much lost it
the Nashville Tennessean wrote quote
Janet Guthrie drove the car they said
she couldn't drive endured the strain
they said she could endure and come
completed the race they said she
couldn't complete the winner David
Pearson who before said he didn't think
she would qualify it and now said he
wouldn't mind racing with her any time
suddenly Janet is a huge star she gets
book offers movie offers companies are
talking endorsements owners call trying
to steal their way from Volstead she she
was told he boasted had never won Indy
and his car sucked and she needed you
away from him but she felt loyal and
just she couldn't do it the next race
she was in the car couldn't finish so
they're right so they're right but at
the same time Richard Penney what ugly
quote she's no lady if she was a lady
she wouldn't be sitting in a racecar
with these other cats how great is it
the last name is petty I know it's
[ __ ] amazing
it's just [ __ ] you've gotta be few last
name is petty if your name's Danny
sarcastic you're like I don't I'm dumb I
don't do sarcasm why I just it's really
bad dad look for me bad looks a
different look for me the owner of the
Texas World Speedway began a stop Janet
movement drivers kept saying a female
driver would go slow and get one of them
killed
even though she's just whatever yeah
even though she's getting movie offers
over how well she just did in Daytona
the paper headline was quote beware
gentlemen Guthrie's in Daytona
at Darlington security refused to let
Janet enter for practice they pointed
it's sign that said no women allowed
then Richard Petty said Janet had a race
under her belt and if she made a mistake
now the veteran drivers would sent her
quote spinning into the infield Jesus
God
racetrack started scheduling her
inspection last which gave her less time
to practice drivers started swerving and
blocking her after one race cale
yarborough is said she had almost
wrecked someone twice and that she
needed to go quote she was trying to
prove a point
now she ought to go home she will never
be competitive but then the driver who
he said got into it with her was like no
it was just a normal deal that everybody
does it was it was it's racing right not
everyone treated her like a crazy
intruder Bobby Allison and Mario
Andretti Andretti said that she had
earned their respect
so it's all great sure
record crowds were turning out so she's
she's [ __ ] selling out all over the
place
tracks her bank in cash this is just
after the oil crisis so spending money
on the race kind of a big deal Janet
then got a sponsor temp company Kelly
girl she's being recognized everywhere
the press is swarming her Paul Newman
helped her get a Hollywood agent
Rika's Newman's into into Newman's a big
race racing guy so there's her car now
Kelly girl nice on the track she held
her own bumping and going hard against
guys like Richard Petty and Carl she's
[ __ ] hitting it on the track the
misogyny remain relentless nasty letters
taunts on pit row and it started to
where Janet down especially because she
had not crashed or performed badly in
any race yet it was not stopping well I
would also imagine that if you are in
that situation like and it's not going
anywhere
you are like at some point I'm going to
have like there's going to be a mistake
or like I'm not a perfect human yeah
you're on a rope like so at some point I
will
maybe have an issue everybody has be so
blown out of proportion so [ __ ]
rookie so right yeah she's gonna make
mistakes but she's not allowed to make
MINIX were like less of a chance yeah
yeah it's just pretty much women getting
involved in anything right especially
right so she hasn't crashed it's not
stopping
she keeps she keeps thinking she's
proved herself already yeah and that it
would and then she'd wake up there be
another newspaper attacking her she's
like I [ __ ] what do you got what do I
have to do yeah
individually drivers would be kind but
then a week later would totally ignore
she told the press quote there
emotionally threatened I can't wait to
blow the doors off the track guys
Volstead bought her a new Indy car a
lightning it was a very fast car but
dick Simon is the number one driver on
the team and he's now in the shadow of
Janet who's getting all the attention
and he's also having to hustle to get
sponsors he landed a lot of land head
pieces for men and was forced to wear a
toupee as part of the sponsor deal oh my
god I've never heard and he wears a
helmet anyway no under the helmet they'd
really like you to wear this why'd you
do it I have no choice it's better to
pay it is it's a sponsor you also around
a lot of wind it's probably just like
it's not I mean I don't care but it's
weird it's really a weird ass so so we
got a needy sponsor I'm not no mine
we got a condom sponsor well I'm not
walking around with a you are what what
and there's gonna be one on the antenna
well that means the toupee people are
out at least right we're also putting an
antenna on the car it's a big con I'm
the one for
your car it's like six feet that's gonna
be hard to drive through it might slow
you down it will slow me down but but
it's a good sponsor okay big hearts
great great it's tough so so the
depository cars here so this lightning
this new car is better than dick Simon's
car
well it's certainly better than dick
Simon's deal and yes and Simon he's the
lead driver so he's supposed to get all
the best [ __ ] so he doesn't like that
she has this new car and he also keeps
blowing up engines and yes we're to pay
so at some point Volstead can't afford a
new engine so being the lead driver he
gets Janet's engine okay so now she has
a car with no engine the perfect more
fair quality and she has to pull out of
a race in May Simon said in an interview
with the Chicago Tribune quote if I had
the same right as Guthrie I guarantee
you I'd win the race in my opinion she's
driving the number one car the speedway
switched and he said she didn't have the
experience to win the 500 then he didn't
have a car he could win with so Simon
and Janet's friendship is over right she
started in the third row at Indy after
getting the lightning up to a hundred
and eighty eight miles per hour in
qualifying Janet Guthrie was the first
woman to qualify for Indy okay she made
headlines across the country Jane Pauley
of The Today Show interview her and
asked quote we put on makeup for the
race
Jane Pauley no will you put on makeup
for the race what all women are wanting
to know I [ __ ] press a lot ever it'll
never change
it'll never [ __ ] chain I mean unless
we are able to just it's just relentless
a lot of male drivers couldn't take it
AJ Foyt who had almost given her his
other car now that she's qualified so he
clearly assumed she would never [ __ ]
qualify that actually was what I was
just thinking is that in reality there
were not two camps of people who were
against her and people who wanted to
give her a shot there were two camps
people who were against her and people
who didn't want to publicly be against
her I'm waiting for her to hang herself
and then she'll go away yeah so he must
have he must have let her drive the car
cuz remember he took it back up she
tested yeah so what happened was she
went on tested and did well no no you're
a threat right yeah there's people who
didn't believe she could do it and then
there were people who didn't believe she
would do it so now AJ Foyt said quote
she might be able to outrun us if one of
us gets ripped but that's the only way
it's getting the shit-talk is getting
weaker yeah it's not great when the race
started Simon got in front of her and
took his foot off the gas she hit her
she had to hit her brakes at 170 miles
an hour and was clearly worried someone
would hit her from behind which is what
he was trying to make happen yeah yeah
she got lucky
it was obviously insanely dangerous for
Simon that's why men can't be out there
soon after it became apparent something
was wrong with the car she had to pit
three times in a few laps at one point
methanol flooded the cockpit while they
were trying to fix the car Jenna was
covered in it but she refused to get out
still after pit stop after pit stop she
called it a desert a hurt her first
IndyCar race was a disaster first 8,500
but she qualified and thought that would
put all the arguments to rest call it a
qualifying is a big deal I'm sure it did
Genoa back to NASCAR while waiting for
any racing to start up again at Daytona
she was named the top rookie she made 10
top 10 nascar finishes that year but
still no sponsor for Indy she personally
started cold calling major corporation
executives
nothing hundreds no one would say why
they weren't sponsoring her just that it
wasn't that she was a woman there's not
meanwhile guys that weren't as close to
as good as her we're getting sponsors
it's not that she was a woman it's that
she's not a man
the difference nuance she got a
marketing Zek to help her he called
trader vic's
to pitcher okay I got in a got on a
speakerphone call quote I laid it out to
a big group of them and then they all
started laughing like hell and hung up
on me everyone was passing she had huh
so she's selling out tracks yeah she is
she's making everybody money she is
totally unique no one in the country
will sponsor her right
she had hundreds of rejections meanwhile
Ladies Home Journal named her Sports one
over the year she was attending tons of
galas and ceremonies and being you know
getting lauded tons of press everyone
loves her but no money no sponsor crazy
and she couldn't race at India without a
sponsor Volstead had to sell the
Lightning because he was running out of
money and then Janet went on Good
Morning America and laid out her case
what kind of makeup you're gonna be
where she'd perform well as a race car
driver for two years the stands were
sold out because of her she was working
the year at octane Daytona but she could
not get a sponsor after her appearance
Texaco called and ofter offered her a
hundred K which is just five percent of
what top any teams got but she can be in
the race she qualified at 15th once the
race was under way she got comfortable
and started passing cars she passed dick
Simon and moved up to 11th and Jen and
ended up finishing ninth newspapers
around the country noted she finished
ahead of racers like Mario Andretti
Johnny Parsons and Rick Mears Janet
Guthrie had proved she belonged
after that 1978 showing she assumed her
career was just kicking off but Texaco
moved on and she was back to cold
calling for sponsors amazingly some of
the biggest douche bags were now saying
nice things Richard Petty quote she come
in just as herself had done a decent job
she come in the hard way because no one
really welcomed her you have to admire
her for that did you dick hole
ah even Bobby unser quote I got it mitt
I had my doubts about her but she's
proving her point she can compete but
why were the saying this because she
wasn't competing right because no one
would give her money two years went by
and she was only able to race in seven
races so a female reporter from the New
York Times sought her out because Janet
it all but disappeared Janet quote what
I am made to do is drive cars I deeply
regret that I don't have the opportunity
to do so you tell me why it was pretty
clear the people who ran the sport no
longer wanted her involved so right so
the people who run NASCAR an Indy are
clearly calling sponsors and saying
you're not sponsoring this one mm-hmm
she's in bad shape she can't sleep she
got diagnosed with depression insomnia
which if I I've had it's [ __ ]
terrible
you wake up every you go to sleep for
two hours and you wake up but you can't
go back to sleep oh yeah quote I cannot
tell you how difficult it was it was
absolutely totally perfectly horrible
she said she wanted to throw herself out
of window she moved to Aspen and gave
racing lessons and lectures around the
country when all the [ __ ] racecars
heard she was out they gloated and
started talking [ __ ] again told you
in 1989 Janet married an airline pilot
she still got tons of fan mail after
years she got over the loss of not being
able to do what she wanted what she was
best at because she was a woman she
relished watching attitudes change over
the years
dick Simon retired in his 50s and went
on to sell yachts in California
Janet's helmet and race suit are in the
Smithsonian she was one of the first
elected to the International Women's
Sports Hall of Fame and she was inducted
into the international Motorsports Hall
of Fame in 2006
she's now greeted warmly at Indy when
she goes in 2001 Sarah Fisher finished
second at the Indy car 2001 infinity
Grand Prix of Miami in 2008 Danica
Patrick became the first woman to win an
IndyCar race she finished third at the
Indy 500 a year later Kyle Petty Kyle
Petty
yeah Richard Petty's son called Danika
quote a marketing machine and said quote
Danica is not a racecar driver because
normally a not a race car driver wins a
race yeah in 2013 former Formula One
legend Stirling Moss said quote I think
women have the strength but I don't know
if they've got the mental aptitude to
race hard wheel to wheel the mental
stress I think would be pretty difficult
for a lady to deal with in a practical
fashion I just don't think they have the
aptitude to win a Formula One race
Richard Petty said Danica who had who
jumped into NASCAR just laid on could
only win if quote everybody else stayed
home it's interesting reading the the
hate of Danica Patrick mm-hmm because
they're really bitter that she's getting
all of these sponsorships which is the
opposite of what happened to the first
woman mm-hmm who is also attractive and
they say it's all only cause Danica
Patrick is but attractive people get
more sponsorships that's just sort of
the way it works
but Danica Patrick who won a [ __ ] race
she won an Indy car race Chelsea came in
third at the Indy 500 so when you say
she's not a racecar driver you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Kyle Petty's a
lying piece of [ __ ] little and is a
little bit she's a little crybaby
[ __ ] [ __ ] a woman we're on the race
a man up yeah
[ __ ] take it I don't I don't like the
way that you get put into these places
halls of fame that in your lifetime that
were rejected you you know what I mean
like the idea that like right so she's
turned away these places actively
undercut and made it impossible for her
to have a fair shot yeah and then there
like we celebrate your story
yeah but like her story could have been
way more if you had just if there's if
there's a description of what they did
to her in the hall you know sitting the
Hall of Fame I guess your little area
right yeah hopefully there's description
saying we [ __ ] her yeah royally I mean
in a Thursday it's [ __ ] if it's just
like she was the first woman to finish
an Indy race yeah that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] or or if you're if you're going
like she fought the patriarchy to find a
way to actually compete and she did she
competed a few like that's not the story
no like the story is she did this while
we and and coulda done more but we
completely undercut it and made it
impossible
I mean imagine like as soon as she
finished ninth they were like oh we
gotta stop this and they went out and I
know what they did as sponsors but
completely hosed her yeah they just they
froze her out yeah and it's just [ __ ]
amazing that they were so [ __ ] scared
that a woman would win that that's what
they did yeah cuz that's all it is
yeah they were terrified that a woman
wouldn't win a race and they would all
look like what [ __ ] girlie man I
don't know what the [ __ ] I think you
would also be what would you deep deep
deep down the fear is that it's just
more competition for your spot
yeah problem so you're you're any any
young women it's different if women can
get into racing no no and have 25% of
the sport all of a sudden becomes women
I was just thinking when you're and
you're a middle road driver why that why
that was reading about this I was
thinking it's no different than when
there were no african-americans allowed
to play baseball well the best players
were in the Negro League yeah right and
and so everything that that the white
guys did is pretty meaningless because
yeah you weren't allowing everyone in
and and when Dana Danica Patrick can
finish first another woman can finish
second
that means all of your racing before
that these [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah because
you weren't allowing open open fair
competition yeah you weren't lying open
for a competition so Richard Petty can
act like he's the [ __ ] king of
anything we're the king of of not
allowing half the people in a race
that's what's [ __ ] it's like in and
in racing he is they'll be like he's one
of the best but you're like yeah but he
like he wouldn't he shunned competition
it also reminds me a little bit of
Michael Sam do you remember him he was
the first gay football player drafted oh
yeah the coverage of it and he didn't he
like he was not like an amazing player
he was like a good college player he was
a prospect and all that stuff and and he
probably you know a little bit like some
athletes like you mean Kaepernick or
even Tim Tebow to some extent they you
don't get brought on a team where you
should or when you should because you
kind of have a media circus following
you but the Michael salmon was
particularly abhorrent because they
covered him he was just like he was just
on this you know human oddity yes yeah
and what they started reporting on him
there was a report on him about what his
teammates thought of him showering and
it was just like what [ __ ] world
could you ask any other player in the
NFL about a teammate showering habits
yeah and think that it's not insane well
the and the other part of that is guess
what there's a ton of gay guys in the
NFL yeah there's a ton of gay guys in
baseball there's trying to get guys
investigate sports they're there they're
a percentage of the population and
therefore they're a percentage of all
sports that's just how it works and I've
actually heard that that on squads
totally everybody knows who's gay and
nobody [ __ ] cares it's the fans that
they're worried about and so when the
guy comes out and I treat him like that
but on the other hand you know there's
the soccer player
it was playing in England and he wanted
to come out and he's like I just can't
it's just not gonna work and he left the
team and then the LA Galaxy were like
we don't [ __ ] care come play for us
and nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah
like literally nobody gave a [ __ ] it was
like just like others a guy playing all
the fear was totally I'm on you know not
based on anything except in this case in
the Sam case it's all the press that's
really what it was it was the me it was
the watching the watch my ESPN did with
Michael Sam was it was a total train
wreck and it end what it does is it ends
up hurting his chances yeah because
you've now made you know he's not it's
not like a thing that's mentioned about
him it's the only thing that you talk
about right and that just like you said
I mean there is just these organizations
as open as they pretend they are in any
sport they have a bottom line and that's
what they pay attention to and until
people are like minded and right minded
they're not going this right let this
you know be open so there's just two
minutes there watch sports that well and
there's just and there's just you know
you need like what what she needs what
she needed what any of these people need
is they need other brave people to and
who have a voice and a platform to be
like you know this / this is a person
that's how I view this person well there
were there were there were like Mario
Andretti and other guys who stood up and
yeah it like no she [ __ ] belongs here
she's [ __ ] but there were more there
more than her like she can't and then
there are the middle people there were
the people that were nice to her in
private and then [ __ ] are in public
and those of the worst that's here in
the way those are the [ __ ] worst
because you're in those are the people
who are driving slow in the fast lane
[Laughter]